l'un des enfants on a vu que l'ia
étaient déjà utilisés à grande échelle
en fait petit à petit l'ia est en train
de s'immiscer partout dans nos vies et
d'être de plus en plus influente dans
nos sociétés oui parce que même lorsqu
elles n'ont qu'un rôle suggestif les
suggestions désir influence grandement
nos décisions c'est un petit peu tout le
principe de l'économie de l'attention
sauf que ces suggestions ne sont pas
forcément conforme avec nos valeurs
morales et parfois ça fait scandale par
exemple aux états unis cela fait
plusieurs années que les juges utilisent
désir basique pour estimer le risque de
récidive de criminels alors la justesse
des prédictions des ja sont loin d'être
parfaite mais ça on pouvait s'y attendre
prédire la récidive est un problème
difficile pour lequel il est illusoire
d'espérer avoir des conclusions
déterministe et en fait les imprécisions
de l'ia n'ont pas fait scandale ce qui a
fait scandale
c'est le biais raciste dans les
prédictions de lire et il est assez
effrayant le voici résumée dans ce
tableau le truc troublant c'est que les
assurés steam assez nettement le risque
de récidive des noirs tandis qu'elle
sous-estiment tout aussi nettement celui
des blancs il y assemble assez
clairement biaisé contre les noirs en un
sens ces tirs et raciste malheureusement
il ne s'agit là que d'un cas parmi tant
d'autres en 2016 microsoft a fait
scandale après avoir dû retirer une ja
happ l'etei un jour après son lancement
theillet thénia en charge du compte
twitter tate 8 et interagissez avec
d'autres utilisateurs de twitter
sauf que twitter c'est comment dire
c'est twitter et il se retrouva vite
entouré de troll cliquer et gratuite et
7,8 et plus scandaleux en l'espace de
quelques jours
taye en vain à nier l'holocauste à
s'attaquer aux noirs et aux mexicains et
à faire des appels au génocide
heureusement que tel n'avait pas le
contrôle de drones tueurs l'exemple de
taye montre d'ailleurs très bien d'où
vient le racisme désir
lysiane ne sont généralement pas
programmé pour être raciste elles sont
souvent programmés avec un certain
objectif assez neutre mais il se trouve
que leur objectif est atteint en copiant
et en généralisant les données qui leur
sont fournis or si on lâche et ziya sur
internet ou sur des jeux de données
sujets ô paradoxe simpson dont on a
parlé dans l'épisode 15
elles y trouveront toutes sortes de
raisons de devenir raciste
typiquement ce n'est pas parce que
google images je retourne plein d' image
d' homme en costard cravate quand on
tape pdg que seuls les hommes avec des
cravates
prendre des postes à responsabilité oui
il ne faut pas oublier qu'il ya
énormément de facteurs de confusion dans
les résultats de google images
autre exemple quand je tape masse
matthysen ça me sera plein d'individus
décédé à croire que la lignée des
mathématiciens est en voie d'extinction
autrement dit même si leur objectif
final n'a pas de biais unies ap
parfaitement en apprendre non pas parce
que l'ia est fondamentalement méchante
raciste ou sexiste mais parce que les
données auxquels il est exposé et
l'invite à être biaisé alors on pourrait
croire qu'il suffit dès lors de des
biaiser les données que l'on fournit aux
ja sauf qu'en lever les billets dans les
données est un problème souvent très
difficile en lui-même typiquement c'est
le cas du langage comme l'illustrent une
dérangeante découverte faite via world
check
souvenez-vous watts vrai qu'il ya dont
on a parlé dans les épisodes 21 et 22
introduite en 2013 par google wow tu
veilles permet d'extraire de la
sémantique du langage naturel et même de
manipuler cette sémantique à l'aide d'
additions et des soustractions en
particulier dans l'épisode 22 on a vu
que d'après world studec roi - sommes
plus ferme est égal à rennes et le plus
fou c'est que cette équation a été
découverte par world to make ne faisant
que lire des textes de la langue
française
ok jusque là on envie de dire que word
studec n'est clairement pas sexiste
après two world to make me fait
qu'étudier des mots avec le simple
objectif d'identifier des régularités
statistiques
et pourtant what to make a aussi conclu
que docteur - sommes plus femme est égal
à infirmière ou dit autrement
selon wood tuvéri la version féminine du
docteur et l'infirmière en particulier
c'est un garçon et une fille demander
tous deux à watts avec quelques arrières
suivre pour soigner des malades alors
world check aura de bonnes chances de
conseiller aux garçons de devenir
docteur et à la fille de devenir
infirmière
de façon plus générale si on ne cherche
pas nous-mêmes a programmé des valeurs
morales dans une île alors lire sera en
fait très probablement en déphasage par
rapport à notre moral or les ja sont de
plus en plus utilisées et ont un pouvoir
de plus en plus important sur nos
sociétés
du coup même si vous ne croyez
absolument pas à l'éventualité d'y à
deux niveaux humain devrait néanmoins
vous semblez urgent de programmer des
valeurs morales dans les ja
d'aujourd'hui à moins que à moins que
vous dites qu'on ne peut pas faire
confiance aux ir pour être moral et il
vaut mieux du coup complètement s'en
débarrasser mais anton conséquentialiste
il nous faut alors nous demander quelle
serait l'alternative est bien
sao dia il faudrait alors en revenir
uniquement à des décisions prises par
des humains sauf que les humains sont
aux aussi sujet à des bières racistes ou
sexistes
pire encore nous sommes souvent très
inconscient de nos propres biais
typiquement comme on en a déjà parlé
les juges sont inconsciemment plus
sévère lorsqu'ils sont affamés il
discrimine donc les personnes
incriminées en fonction de l'heure de
jugement et de même comme on en a déjà
parlé au moment d'aborder le paradoxe de
simpson certaines données montrent que
les juges américains sont plus sévères
envers les criminels noirs et envers les
criminels dont les victimes sont
blanches et ne sont sans doute pas les
seuls
il est difficile d'imaginer que des
informations comme la couleur de peau ou
le sexe des candidats pour un job
n'influence pas inconsciemment les
décisions des recruteurs en fait des
expériences de psychologie suggère que
nous sommes tous victimes de bié raciste
inconscients qui nous pousse à être plus
prompts à associer certains groupes
ethniques à certaine connotation pire
encore nos billets inconscient de bonnes
chances d'avoir des effets importants
que l'on sous-estiment grandement une
expérience de psychologie à oak school
l'a parfaitement mise en évidence et l'a
appelé l'effet pygmalion
l'expérience est la suivante on prend
une classe de primaire au hasard au
début de l'année un chercheur de harvard
fait passer un test aux élèves
puis ils tirent au hasard cinq élèves
dans la casse edit à l'enseignant de
primaire que ces cinq élèves ont
particulièrement réussi le test et qui
ne serait pas surprenant qu'ils
progressent nettement au cours de
l'année autrement dit la seule variable
qui change entre un des cinq élèves et
n'importe lequel des autres c'est ce que
l'enseignant pense du potentiel de ses
élèves à la fin de l'année le chercheur
faire passer un test à toute la classe
eh bien devinez quoi le biais de
l'enseignant a conduit un billet
l'enseignement les cinq élèves qui
avaient été tirés au hasard ont
nettement plus progressé que les autres
mois il ya des petits bémols à mettre
cette histoire nous avons le fait que ça
marche particulièrement bien pour les
petites cases comme le cp mais comme on
parle de david dans sa vidéo sur le
racisme inconscient
d'autres expériences suggèrent que des
dynamiques similaires ont lieu dans bien
d'autres cas par exemple en entreprise
nos billets inconscient influence
légèrement la manière dont on interagit
les uns avec les autres et de manière
imperceptible
on en vient à discriminer les individus
en fonction de ses biens est inconscient
ceux qui modifient leurs chances de
développement personnel sachant cela il
me semble inopportun de chercher à
refouler noblet inconscient et à
prétendre qu'il n'existe pas
nous avons des billets admettons de
notre environnement social et culturel
les informations biaisées auxquels nous
sommes exposés ou la simple structures
de la langue que l'on utilise nous
pousse à plus promptement associer
certains individus à certaines
caractéristiques nous avons tendance à
donner des camions garçons et des
poupées aux filles et de manière
inconsciente est imperceptible
on en vient à traiter très différemment
différents individus en fonction
notamment de leur apparence physique
dès lors il me semble préférable de
prendre pleinement conscience de nos
biens est inconscient je suis
inconsciemment racistes sexistes et tout
ce que vous voulez je le sais si on me
raconte une histoire
je vais avoir tendance à l'interpréter
en fonction de mes bien conscient sans
que je ne m'en rende compte et j'ai bien
peur que mes capacités cognitives soit
trop limité pour espérer des biaisé mon
inconscient ceci étant dit en étant
conscient de mes billets inconscient je
peux chercher à rectifier le tir à
l'image d'un joueur de fléchettes qui
tirent toujours légèrement à droite de
la cible
quand ils visaient la cible il me semble
qu'il s'agit davantage de la bonne
manière de penser les problèmes de
discrimination comme on parle aussi
monsieur fille il nous faut prendre
conscience du rôle central de notre
inconscience en effet il semblerait que
conscience en a conscience ne soit que
ruine de l'âme
ceci étant dit même en étant conscients
de notre inconscience il n'est pas dit
qu'il soit possible de rectifier
correctement les biais de notre
inconscient
pire il semble impossible d'amener tous
les humains à prendre conscience de leur
inconscient et à rectifier leurs biens
ni même de se faire pour une proportion
non négligeable d'humains les humains
sont des machines difficile à programmer
ce qui me semble bien plus faisable
c'est de rectifier les biais des
machines
en fait les ja pourrait même être nos
meilleurs alliés pour lutter contre nos
biens est inconscient au plus d'équité
dans nos sociétés l'utilisation désir
pourrait en fait être une priorité à
condition bien sûr de d'abord le
renseigner adéquatement et valeurs
morales la nerv en a parlé du théorème
delaunay et vincent palmieri fait
remarquer que le terme de bourges est
notamment celui qui parle de la fixation
du terme ce que j'appelais le terme de
fixation à vis de précédentes
il affirme que en fait si au lieu de
rajouter une blouse jacques chirac on
tire une boule rouge on rajoute un
milliard de boule rouge et qu'on tire à
nouveau en fait là encore il n'y aurait
pas fixation et qu'il y aura une
certaine proportion de boules rouges et
de boue
qui n'attendraient pas vers uniquement
des rouges ou uniquement des bleus est
extrêmement contre intuitif
quand vous avez vu ces matières ce qui
va se passer c'est du coup très
probablement la distribution des boules
rouges et bleus sera alors un nombre
aléatoire et clairement ce nombre
aléatoire ne sera pas une distribution
uniforme il ça risque d'être une courbe
qui y voit là dedans pas mal sur les
côtés mais il n'y aura pas fiscalisation
dans le sens où avec probabilité 1 à
l'infini la proportion de bleu rouge
sera un certain nombre strictement entre
0 et 1 mais ne sera ni 0 nîmes silvain
fayard demande que se passerait-il si au
lieu d'avoir deux couleurs on avait
maintenant plusieurs couleurs donc au
lieu d'avoir juste les vidéos comédie
les vidéos drame aussi les vidéos de
vulgarisation de make up et tout ça si
on a plusieurs catégories comme ça deux
vidéos
en fait il se passerait encore la même
chose et turan de l'oned en particulier
toujours tout comme le théorème de
douleur reste et notamment dans le cas
du littoral delaunay ça voudrait dire
que il y aurait une fixation de chacun
des utilisateurs sur un type de vidéos
et si la probabilité paix et d'avoir un
truc qui vient des trending est
inférieur à 1 2 me alors on aura d'un
côté les conformistes et de l'autre côté
les anti conformiste et pour en savoir
plus ce jour encore une fois les jeux
terminés à la thèse de michael owen est
devant remy rien dans la description
patrice verlaine demande aussi des
méthodes bélizienne ne serait pas
immunisé contre ce risque de fixation en
fait c'est pas très claire alors
première chose il ya un point assez
important à souligner c'est que si on
applique la formule belge naïve en
supposant que les choix d'un utilisateur
sont indépendants de son historique par
exemple si assez bizarre comme peut-être
mais bon voilà si on suppose ça c'est
quand même un finalement une hypothèse
qu'on retrouve assez souvent en fait tu
vois on cherche à ajouter les hypothèses
d'indépendance parce que ça sera
publiquement devant les calculs et si on
fait ça en ce moment là on voit que la
forme de bayes on tient une
multiplication ton combatif icm en cas
de renforcement exponentielle mais bien
sûr maintenant si on prend les
dépendances d'un tirage à l'autre alors
on peut avoir des trucs tout à fait
différent et a priori
on aurait des trucs vraiment différent
tout cas dans le cas d'un utilisateur
qui cliquent au hasard si on essaie de
deviner sur quoi il a plus de chance de
cliquer à la formule de bayes nonda yves
devrait réussir à prendre en compte et a
pas raconter n'importe quoi
ceci étant dit le poème de choisir les
vidéos à montrer aux utilisateurs est un
poème qui en fait sort du cadre
bayésiens puisqu'il s'agit d'un problème
de prise de décision alors que la
formule baisse nous dit que des choses
sur ce qu'il faut penser ce qu'il faut
croire c'est encore une fois une formule
lui savoir de la philosophie ça
appartient au champ de la philosophie de
la connaissance mais ça peut appartient
pas au champ de la prise de décision
même si bien sûr il ya beaucoup de liens
entre la théorie la prise de décision et
la théorie de qu'est-ce qu'il faut
savoir puisque pour bien point de
décision il faut bien savoir ce qui se
passe en particulier si l'objectif est
de montrer à nos utilisateurs des vidéos
sur lequel il ya plus de chances de
cliquer et bien des conseils qu'il a
plus tendance à cliquer sur les vidéos
rouge chaussures et vidéos bleus eh ben
il ya tout intérêt à mettre le paquet à
ne mettre que des vidéos rouge bref tout
ça pour dire que si les utilisateurs ont
vraiment une légère préférence entre le
bleu et le rouge alors très probablement
iñaki fini par le comprendre et qui dont
l'objectif est de maximiser le nombre de
clics finira par avoir de la fixation
c'est à dire de montrer à utilisateurs
que des vidéos qui lui corresponde qui
appartient à sa bulle
enfin la finlande à nous demande aussi
du coup il vaudrait pas mieux que ce
soient les utilisateurs qu'ils puissent
paramétrer une certaine manière les
vidéos auxquels ils veulent être exposés
exposés et le problème en fait avec ce
raisonnement c'est que très probablement
la plupart des utilisateurs ne vont pas
vouloir bidouiller les paramètres et
même si l'utilisateur bidouillait les
paramètres en fait il y aura quand même
un risque que les utilisateurs
choisissent d'être exposée aux vidéos
auxquels ils veulent être exposés
alors certes c'est possible qu'il y ait
quelques personnes qui préfèrent a
vraiment une diversité et être heures
passées par tous mais si on raisonne en
termes d'altruisme efficace on essaie de
raisonner à grande échelle notamment de
voir l'impact global de ce mécanisme de
file tory bugs et
deux choix en fait du contenu auquel on
veut être exposés on se rend compte
qu'en fait il s'agit d'un problème très
globale puisque très probablement 99%
peut-être comme katrina vers une 86 9%
de la population va sans doute préféré
être exposés uniquement à des vidéos qui
vont dans leur sens qui vous disent ce
qu'ils veulent entendre
et du coup là on a vraiment un problème
fondamental et l'algorithme de youtube
s'il est personnalisable par les
utilisateurs
ça n'arrangerait absolument pas ça ne
résoudrait absolument pas ce problème
en fait je suis plutôt du genre à penser
que pour vraiment résoudre ce problème
la meilleure façon de faire c'est encore
de passer par l'algorithme de youtube et
quelques pas inclure dans la grogne de
youtube des valeurs morales qui il sait
revenir le force à exposer un petit peu
les différents utilisateurs à des vidéos
peut-être plus intelligente peut-être
qu'ils vont un petit peu à l'encontre de
ce à quoi ils pensent de sorte à avoir
des informations moins biaisée par
chacun des utilisateurs
bien sûr ce point là il se débat tout
comme les questions de morale de façon
plus générale
et si je pense que c'est assez important
de jours d'avoir ce débat moral sur ce
qui est bien normalement est ce que les
il devrait faire mais bien sûr avoir ce
genre de discussion est très très très
difficile des termes ans à cause de
l'organisme bien sûr et du coup c'est je
pense que c'est très important que au
préalable on apprenne à mieux débattre
ensemble et à mieux réfléchir ensemble à
mieux notamment comprendre les positions
des uns et des autres et c'est sur ces
paroles quelque peu moralisatrice et je
suis désolé pour cela que je vais
conclure elle j'espère qu'ils avaient
aimé cette vidéo ces questions de biais
des algorithmes et c'est l'une des
grandes questions éthiques du moment et
de recherche notamment en intelligence
artificielle et il ya un autre sujet
tout aussi important moralement que ce
problème de thé biais faciste sexy tout
autre il s'agit du poème de la vie
privée qui notamment intimement liée au
problème des assurances et sociaux dont
on parlera dans la prochaine vidéo si
vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à la
ligue et à la commenter à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pendant que les
futurs épisodes merci at il peur pour
leurs dons et j'espère que vous serez là
la prochaine fois
hélas les auteurs ont pu mesurer que
pour associer les prénoms blanc avec le
positif et les prénoms noir avec le
négatif les temps de réaction était
autour de 7 100 millisecondes et que
dans l'autre sens
il était de 9 100 millisecondes en
moyenne c'est à dire que les
participants étaient plus rapides quand
il s'agissait de classe et jamel avec
prison et paul avec honnêteté
quand il fallait faire l'inversé